[Music]
my next guest starts on the popular abc
series happy endings let's take a look
okay
it is time
for
the walk out the walk out when guy comes
over i want you to look him right in the
eye and i want you to say to him
what's your best price and when he gives
it to you
i want you to say
no thank you and then i want you to just
calmly
walk out
can you do that yes
yes i can
so ladies
what is your best price did you want the
two door or the phone no thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
this is not a joke uh you you injured
yourself did it happen doing that stunt
that we just saw no oh okay the thing is
that was impressive that was really
funny another uh my son double megan did
that and she actually had to go to
hospital oh so but she's totally fine
and she did a great job making me look
funny right yeah worth it right megan so
what happened so what happened to you
yes i was hurt actually in a scene i was
shooting with damon wayans junior where
i had to slap him over and over again
yeah and so they thought he would be
hurt in fact i was hurt sadly i get hurt
all the time but how would you get hurt
slapping someone else because i inflame
my good question i inflamed my rotator
cuff i did it over and over again and so
basically i've had this sling for two
weeks that's so weird you it sounds like
you you slapped him like 50 times
he's fine he's absolutely fine this
makes him seem so macho i know but i was
i was slapping the air in fairness in
front of him and so i managed to hurt
myself doing basically nothing are you
in pain right now yes do you have any
meds or anything well they gave me
vicodin which i have had to take at
night and sometimes during the day i'm
not on it now
oh wow did you bring any yeah
i'm okay but it's strange to just be on
vicodin during the day like it's it's
not great yeah it's a little weird
that's okay i mean somewhat it's great
of course but to a point to a point
let's be sensible here before we go
you're i know you've got this injury how
long have you been in the sling for uh
two weeks okay
can you pretty much do is it making your
life impossible is it can you pretty
much do everything you want to do with
that i mean sort of it's impacted uh
slightly my ability to flirt
because it's strange to kind of sidle up
to someone you know and try to be sexy
and then you've got this going
give a little of that you get a little
like try to flip your hair and it's just
and then it always comes back to this
guy yeah
dancing is hard oh you've been dancing
with that thing yeah i mean you got to
get down when you can and when you need
to but it's hard again you've got it's
like you just kind of feature it and
like let it
and then try to move it up to the face
but not broken but beautiful yeah i see
very nice yeah wow
you'll be fine thank you